Ciao, ragazzi e benvenuti alla terza puntata di dillo con un'emoji
Questa volta non parleremo delle emoji da non inviare ad una ragazza, ma di tutte quelle emoji
Inutilissime che ci sono, che non useremo mai. Io mi chiedo ma chi è che le ha inventate? Cioè quando mai io invierò una roba del genere
Sono lì giusto per
Occupare spazio. Tipo questa, che cos'è un diavolo o
Un vampiro, cos'è rosso con la criniera? Un leone-diavolo è una figura mitologica
Cos'è, cosa mi rappresenta
Boh, interrogativo. Ma anche questa, ok, abbiamo capito che piace il rosso a
chi ha creato le emoji, quindi queste due maschere rosse molto carine, questo ha un naso molto pronunciato, che
Come si dice dalle mie parti "fa provincia"
Però obiettivamente quando lo dobbiamo usare?
Attendiamo la risposta ma a proposito di emoji che mettono l'ansia, parliamo di queste
Che cos'è utente facebook?
Un omino, non si vede la faccia, una cosa che mi sembra, hai presente i programmi quando intervistano gli assassini? Ecco potrebbe
essere utile in quei casi, perché io parlo tutti i giorni degli assassini che intervisto, che
non vogliono rivelare la loro identità. Tipo questa che c'è uno davanti e uno dietro, mi sa molto comunque di stalking, quindi
c'è non auguro a nessuno di voi di messaggiare, cioè di mandare l'emoji che questo mi sta stalkerando
non creano neanche troppa ansia
Chiudiamo il capitolo ansia e andiamo avanti
Portiamo a casa. Allora tutti voi,
a me compresa è capitato di andare a un concerto e di acquistare dei biglietti. Quello del teoricamente concerto c'è scritto,  scusate ma
devo un attimo allora,
live concert ticket, zona a
Così per non farci mancare niente, però se dico "io vado al concerto" e sono nella zona c
Come faccio?
Comunque è limitativo, questo lo dobbiamo dire. Cioè ticket one ribellati
Imponiti, per avere un biglietto come dio comanda
ma, ho
selezionato anche delle cose non inutili di più e cioè
i doppioni, abbiamo dei doppioni nelle emoji, tipo la luna. Allora la luna
Ce ne sono tre: c'è questa che è quella classica, che ogni tanto si può anche usare. E poi ci sono queste lune
Che si guardano proprio si guardano, si parlano, perché ci sono due lune al mondo
Una di destra e una di sinistra
Hanno la faccia ed è molto albero azzurro non so se lo guardavate, ma comunque la grafica è quella
Che motivo c'era di farne due?
Cioè una già fa schifo, perché fa schifo sta luna. Voglio vedere insomma nessuno la userà mai, ok. Nessuno la usa, che motivo c'è
di farne un'altra. Per non parlare delle lenti, le lenti d'ingrandimento
Ce ne volevi fare una, fanne una, due due! Una a destra e una a sinistra, una che va verso l'interno e una che va verso l'esterno
Ma perché? Stessa cosa per il pupazzo di neve
C'è una piccola variazione
Un pupazzo di neve senza neve e un pupazzo di neve
con la neve
era essenziale
é ovvio che il pupazzo di neve c'è quando c'è la neve, che in quel momento non stia nevicando
non gliene frega niente a nessuno. Perché farne due? Perché sprecare dello spazio? Ma parliamo anche di lei la
spirale. Allora se fosse di un colore tipo mattoncino potrebbe essere uno zampirone,
che comunque in estate si usa
Ma è blu. Che cos'è? Cos'è un ghirigoro? Una
cornicetta? Vi ricordate le cornicette di quando andavamo alle elementari? Ecco quelle. Non ha senso. Proprio da buttare lì così, una spirale
parliamo del ciclismo
Allora ci sono due ciclisti, maschio e femmina ovviamente, perché non siamo razzisti contro l'altro sesso
Senza sfondo e ci sono
ciclisti maschio e femmina in montagna
La domanda è
Ma al mare non si può andare in bici?
I ciclisti al mare non si allenano non corrono, non fanno? Cioè perché?
Perché in montagna si e al mare no? Che cos'è
questo odio nei confronti del mare?
Cioè io sto delineando il profilo di mr emoji, mr emoji è
un uomo che non gliene frega niente della moda, dopo capire perché
Che ama la montagna e l'isolamento
E l'ansia
Gli animali ci sono tutti e va bene, le faccine, le emoji ci sono tutte va bene. A cosa
serviva fare, aspetta le conto, 1 2 3 4 5 6
facce di gatti
uguali alle facce delle emoji normali. C'è quello che piange, c'è quello innamorato, c'è quello che ride, c'è quello malizioso, c'è
quello che dal bacio senza il cuore, quello arrabbiato
Ma anche problemi ha signor emoji? Cioè le piacciono i gatti? Benissimo. Ma era necessario fare
8, 8 gatti che hanno le stesse identiche, non è che dici le faccio diverse, uguali.
Io mi chiedo per quale motivo io voglio mandare la faccina innamorata, per quale motivo devo mandare il gatto innamorato. Ci sono 200 miliardi di veicoli
7 frecciarossa, 8 regionali
Aerei che decollano, volano in tutti i cioè proprio
Rovazzi sponsor
semafori, qualsiasi cosa
E apriamo l'armadio delle emoji, cioè parlando di moda. Se vogliamo parlare di vestiti femminili abbiamo soltanto
questo obbrobrio
e il kimono, perché comunque cioè nell'armadio di tutte le donne italiane un kimono c'è
ci mancherebbe, capito va anche di moda praticamente
Allora io mi, ma questo è un appello che faccio allora
Ci avete messo finalmente, dopo secoli che rompevamo le palle, il dito medio
Facciamo un appello, questa una petizione e vi invito a firmare questa petizione
AMPLIAMO
L'ARMADIO E GLI OUTFIT
POSSIBILI DELLE EMOJI. Ok, io sono cresciuta con gira la moda. Sono una persona molto appassionata di moda. Tutti siamo molto appassionati
di moda, quindi mr emoji veramente
stai al passo con i tempi. Voglio come minimo un tubino nero, cioè un tubino nero, non è che chiedo la luna o no?
Stessa cosa con le scarpe
Che cos'è questo sandalo?
Cos'è Gesù di Nazaret col tacco? O la décolleté rossa, cioè va bene carina
Ci può stare in qualche occasione
ma mettetemela è una décolleté nera. Cioè il classico è il classico, vuoi mettere 3 cagate? Metti almeno quelle del colore giusto, che il vestito azzurro
cioè
Manco Aurora la bella addormentata. Ma concludiamo in modalità
meteo, mi sento molto metereologica oggi, quindi sento molto Giuliacci, sono la figlia illegittima di
Giuliacci. E vorrei parlare di queste emoji, allora la nebbia e il vento
Fondamentale, cioè tutti i giorni, ti sei svegliato, sei a Milano/sei di Milano quindi
Nebbia chiaro, cioè proprio luogo comune. Tutti i giorni usiamo questa, a Milano tutti i giorni  mettiamo questa emoji. Stessa cosa per il vento.
"Ah oggi com'è il tempo?" "Ah tira un po' di vento" E mandi la tipa che
ti soffia il vento, molto Botticelli come mood, molto primavera di Botticelli.
Se il video vi è piaciuto mettete like al video, iscrivetevi al canale e
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social:  facebook
instagram e musical.ly
ADORO! CIAOOO